[Music]
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today let's
catch up a little
bit there is a company called standard
and poor they are one of the companies
that rates things on the stock market
the most famous thing that they rate
there's a company called Dow Jones that
has an average of the industrial
companies which creates the Dow Jones
Industrial Average which is a little
strange because a lot of the companies
are not industrial anymore that are part
of that average old timey term but it
come it comes from the you know when
America was more uh manufacturing driven
than it is today uh the SNP standard and
poor rates the top the largest 500
companies that are publicly traded
meaning their stock is sold on what we
call the big board the New York Stock
Exchange so these are the large largest
500 companies that sell stock in America
and that means they're have that the as
this group of companies goes is a good
indication of what the economy is doing
it's a good indication certainly of what
the stock market is doing because
basically they make up the stock the
vast majority of the stock market so the
top 500 companies on the New York Stock
Exchange is called the SNP standard and
Port S&P 500 now that's important
because that's actually a better way of
measuring what the stock market is doing
than the Dow is okay or the Dow Jones
Industrial Average or any other measure
for that matter this is a very generic
measure and people in the financial
world use the S&P 500 as a as a plum
line to tell what the market is doing so
if a if a mutual fund for instance
outperforms the S&P 500 that means the
mutual fund is making better returns
than the market as a whole
if it underperforms the S&P 500 it makes
less returns so all that's important um
nice article uh James our producer
pulled up for us if the S&P 500 hits a
new all-time high in
24 you can expect a strong year of gains
to follow according to Ned Davis
research the investment firm crunched
the numbers and found that when the S&P
500 hits at least one record high in a
given
year that year 's median return is about
15% so what they're saying is is that
when the when the stock market tops out
and has a new record that is almost
always a year that you get great returns
well duh obviously if the stock market's
hitting a new record you ought to be
getting great returns it kind of makes
sense right so good foreshadowing guys
yeah but I mean it it makes sense it's
an it's an interesting it is it is a
valid statistical correlation so I like
I like the study the S&P 500 has tended
to post double dou digit gains in years
with record highs uh Ned Davis research
said the data point highlights two
typical characteristics of the stock
market that strength begets more
strength and that stocks don't typically
Crash from all-time highs uh so just
because it goes way up generally means
it's going to go up it doesn't mean it's
going to go right back down and that
makes sense of course too of course this
stas is not a slam dunk the S&P is less
than 2% away from hitting a new all-time
high if it were to do that in the next
day or two or the next month or two then
a uh you know a the historical data
indicates that you're going to have a
great year which also makes sense
because it wouldn't have hit a high if
it wasn't had moving towards a great
year but it doesn't just jump up there
and then jump down uh so all this to say
we're close to hitting a new record ever
in the history of the stock market it up
and if it hits that that is a great
indicator that 24 is going to be a great
year to have invested uh which means
that if you're waiting until after the
presidential election in November to do
your investing that's probably a dumb
idea if you got some money you're
sitting on right now I would buy your
mutual fund like tomorrow right now and
if you're thinking about pulling all
your money out because you saw some
headlines don't do that either yeah we
found that if you just ride this roller
coaster over time you're going to hit a
new record high and a new record high
and those and then it's going to go down
and then it's going to come up and then
it's going to go down and then it's
going to come up this is how life works
I mean it's how the real estate it's how
the real estate market works it's how
mutual funds work it's how the whole you
know stock market works the S&P 500 all
this does that so here's the deal you
got 100,000 bucks and you wait till
November and this Market hits and does
what this study indicates and it makes
let's say it makes 15% which was the
average the median okay so $100,000 and
you don't invest it you wait on
November and uh the market goes up 15%
what' you lose
$155,000 because you didn't do what I
just said to do invest so stock and let
me just tell you real estate's exactly
the same place right now is real estate
going to go down no it's not we have a
tremendous shortage of housing there's
more buyers even in a sluggish slow
Market where people are sitting on the
sidelines because interest rates spiked
up now they're coming back down they're
coming off Sidelines in the last two
weeks like never before but
um if you wait a year to buy a house
because you're somehow waiting to time
the market you've got this mysterious
Insight that you think things are going
to go down you're
wrong and if you wait a year to invest
in the market because you're waiting on
the market to come down you're going to
miss
it and if I'm wrong
give it another 12 months and I won't be
wrong because it'll come up I mean
really uh so I I got to tell you what
what Dave what is Dave Ram he doing
right now
buying period investing period I'm not
waiting
on the clash of the old men Trump and
Biden not waiting on two 8 80y Old 80y
olds to have an MMA to decide what I'm
going to do cuz who who the crap knows
one of break a hip well it's it's more
like bumper cars that are running out of
battery bumping into each other more
than a clash it's like two Muppets the
dirt what the old men Muppets right so
Statler and Waldorf is that them that's
him oh my gosh so you don't wait on this
don't sit don't watch Fox News and CNN
and and let your butt sit on the bench
get in the game shoot the
ball fire pull the trigger whatever
whatever metaphor we need to use to
cause you to actually do the investing
Sports Weaponry whatever it takes
whatever it takes to get you moving here
we'll do we'll go whatever whichever
direction you need to go and this
validates a lot of what you've been
saying for 30 years Dave we looked at
historical data in the S&P 500 average
annual return is 10 to 12% and they're
saying right here this is going to could
be a year about 15% median return and
people always go Dave I'm not getting
that in my account well yeah dummy not
in a given one month period Well you see
that but over time the average is the
average that's how averages work
averages I think we all need to go back
to basic math
statistical these these uh these these
sixth grade math classes that people
flunked but yeah that that's the thing
so so all of this to say boys and girls
please be steadily investing please the
people that invest are the ones that
have money there's a high correlation
between people who save money invest
money that have money hello why was that
deep you know if you don't if you don't
put any money in the account please
don't expect any money to be in the
account why is that hard well but just
keep doing it just keep doing it just
keep there's a lot of fear and that's
why I love you know working with a
financial Pro uh smart Vestor Pro great
great person to work with to reach out
to a financial adviser an investment Pro
and go help me understand this and you
make the decisions and they're not going
to pull the money out for you you are
calling the shots here and they're going
to help you understand the perspective
that we're showing you on the show today
yeah you can P up the historical data
and look at the track records look at
the trend lines it's really not hard to
understand I mean it's really not I mean
if you pull up in a neighborhood and
there's cars up on blocks and the
gutters are falling off the houses and
the place everything you see needs weed
eaters then then you know and then you
pull up the MLS data on that
neighborhood and you see the values have
been going down it's not a it doesn't
require rocket surgery to figure out
that this thing's going down in value I
mean you know this is not hard and if
you pull up in the neighborhood and
everything's manicured and it looks like
freaking Leave it to Beaver lives there
you know and you go pull up MLS data on
that you're going to see a line up and
to the right hello well it doesn't take
a rocket surgeon to figure that out
either go buy a house in that
neighborhood this is these are trend
lines it's historical data you can watch
this stuff create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life